[Applause]
[Music]
no more destination no more pain
when he said one thing before i'd
graduated
[Music]
don't you worry we love you more than
you know
[Music]
baby
don't know
[Music]
no more destination no
[Applause]
before more graduated
don't you worry
every day
no
[Music]
hey friends did you think that that park
and public art were pretty cool i
certainly did too
um i must have biked past that spot at
least a hundred times and i never
realized that it was there
uh turns out it's a monument to rachel
carson who wrote the silent spring
and i had no idea that she was
originally a silver spring resident
right here uh in the suburbs around dc
pretty cool huh anyways i just want to
put out a huge thank you to ultra poi
for sponsoring this video and making it
possible for me to go out and play
around with some awesome public art
if you want to pre-order a set of those
orb hoy pro led contact for you that i
was using in this video you can do so
over at ultrapoi.com by using the promo
code rex factor with a zero instead of
an o
that will get you a discount on your
order and it helps up channels so
everybody wins thank you so much to
ultra poi for sponsoring this video and
giving me an opportunity to go out and
play around
um also i we i forgot to uh record a
thank you
with my friend mufasa who once again
handled the camera duties here uh he's
an awesome flow artist in his own right
you should go follow him over on
instagram he is fuego manza does a lot
of great fire spinning and prop
manipulation stuff himself i feel so bad
that we didn't get the chance to do that
video afterwards i was kind of brain
jello anyways go go and follow him
as for other thank yous big thanks to
the friends of the channel
thank you too
dark monk flow fests flow toys higher
terror light toys juggling calling spin
balls and ultra poi for helping to make
the videos on this channel possible uh
you can learn more about all these
amazing companies and work that they're
doing to support flow artists like
yourself by checking out the links that
i have down in the description of this
here video and special thanks to the
first non-business friends of the
channel that is johnny howard lane
machinski and becca beckham thank you
one and all for your very very kind
support
in addition uh this video would not be
possible or not for the kind support of
all of these wonderful people right here
these are my flow patrons over on
patreon and they along with wonderful
people listed down in the description
helps make this video and all the videos
on this channel possible thank you one
and all for your amazing support
um if you would like to support me in my
mission of bringing flow arts and poi
spinning to the entire world and help
people connect with their brains and
their bodies as creative individuals you
can do so by heading on over to
patreon.com drexfactorpoi and signing up
you can do that your link down in the
description or the card that just popped
up if you are watching on youtube there
you can get access to a whole host of
awesome rewards and help me out in my
mission thank you so much go ahead and
give that a look
and with that dear friends i'm gonna go
ahead and go outside and do a little bit
more flowing i'm gonna include a link to
a playlist of other flow videos that
i've done down in the description as
well as up on screen if you're watching
on youtube make sure to get out and flow
today and i will see you with a new
video on friday
peace